giant befehl und was jetzt kommt s echt
episch krebse die stars
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft fakes und zwar
bevor diese folge es losgeht möchte ich
wieder darauf hinweisen dass alle facts
von euch mir per e mail zugesendet
wurden dass ich nicht dafür garantieren
kann dass nicht schon irgend welchen
anderen videos hochgeladen wurden und
die serie lebt von eurem e mails an
kontrast gmail.com da könnt ihr noch
weiter infekt zu senden so und bevor
jetzt wirklich defekts losgehen weil ich
noch einmal das geheimnisvolle geräusche
was ich in der clown modifikation mob
vorstellung dingsbums am ende habe ich
ein geräusch gemacht und zwar war dieses
geräusch dass hier die das spielzeugauto
das habe ich so gedreht und das haben
ein paar leute erwarten
und wer einer davon war wenn ich jetzt
einfach so rausgepickt habe der kriegt
jetzt nix oder so aber der hat es halt
einfach der gewinner jetzt das ist eine
person die es relativ schnell und als
video geschrieben hat und zwar a place
at geschrieben ein spielzeugauto wenn
man das nach hinten fährt die räder sich
von alleine drehen bzw
die räder dafür richtete ein
spielzeugauto gibt es nach hinten
gedreht und ja das war das erste
geheimnisvolle geräusche und ich würde
sagen wir fangen jetzt weiter mit dem
nächsten geheimnisvollen geräusch und
zwar dass hier
ok ich mach's nochmal
schreibt in die kommentare was ihr denkt
was das ist und aktuell wird ein
kommentar im nächsten video irgendwann
mal in einem anderen video erwähnt so
gut und ich will sagen jetzt können auch
schon direkt anfangen mit denen facts
und zwar erstmal danke an trainings
kraft für diesen ersten fade und zwar
wenn ich jetzt mal vier zombies hin
packe gegen die zombies zwar auf diese
kuchen aber das zeigt auch der kleine
schon wenn sie drauf sind wird jeder zum
kreis der zombie jeder zombie springt im
kreis denn der zombie jetzt stehen
bleibt dann kann er entweder wieder
zurückgehen und alles ist gut oder geht
auf den zweiten kuchen sag ich jetzt mal
und dann wird er da halt wieder wenn er
auf dem zweiten kuchen ist so hoch
springen und immer so einen kreis
springen das ist auch so wenn ich ihr
jetzt weiß ich wenn ich drauf sie begeht
das glaube ich nicht
wenn ich darauf schieben nicht aber er
zum beispiel dreht jetzt wieder im kreis
verletzt ein kuchen weitergegangen ist
ja dreht sich jetzt auch im kreis der
kleine hab ich grad nur aufgeschoben
wird sie weise die sind schon so
aufgegangen so er dreht sich auch wieder
am kreis der kleine dreht sich da auch
im kreis oder macht heftige bewegungen
der springt hüpft ihr heftig als
sennerin 100 eine medaille
wer hier er macht einfach nix ja erst
herum
okay gut aber wenn sich jetzt irgendwie
von dem bewegt könnte ich euch 100 euro
schweren das ja ok er ist jetzt
natürlich einfach den anderen weg
gelaufen aber er springt auch wieder am
kreis und jetzt fängt es einfach mal an
für wegmann nein
und da sind wir auch schon zurück beim
zweiten effekt und zwar bin ich dafür
mal wieder aus meiner anderen effekt
welt rausgewählt werden bei diesen
effekt den kann ich nur dieser welt hier
vorstellen also in einer etwas anderen
welt weil in der anderen welt in der
minecraft welt ging das irgendwie nicht
und zwar ist es der samen wild befehl
und was jetzt kommt s echt ey du kleiner
kombi
ich kann ihnen jetzt von hier oben nicht
lagen sondern ich muss schon direkt
daneben stehen dann kann ich den schlag
und dann der reagiert wie ein normaler
zombie auch und der hüpf doch nicht so
weit weg also da hüpft doch so weit weg
wie ein normaler zum widerstand der ist
halb zwölf blöcke großen der ist einfach
mega riesig das ist so krass
der ist echt heftig groß er soll es bei
ihm in die kamera hier gucken gucken die
kamera
in die kamera hey hey die pizza das eben
eine vollbild drauf habt ihr eben guck
mal hier
du sollst mich angucken hey du bist
europäischer guck mir jetzt an programme
besser da ich hab dich doch nicht
umsonst hat den gang gesetzt das
hauptgeschäft haben eine position zu
kommen
dabei waren fast nur gute freunde das
ist der unser neues riesenbaby wir
können hier auch so einen hamann giant
samantha man sein also mit diesem befehl
sargent kammern giganten spawnen in der
minecraft welt und die sind echt
gigantisch grad heftig grad
und ja sehen halt aus wie zombies haben
auch die gleiche pixelanzahl und ich bin
in meinem kopf drin
kommen wir zu viert nummer 3 und zwar
können hexen nicht verbrennen also ich
habe jetzt einfach mal so eine kleine
defekte gespannt bibi blocksberg du
kleine hexe kann man zeigt und was du
kein neuer nokia spaß was für laden
umgesprungen
ich kann jetzt einfach mal die blöcke
anzünden und auf denen die steht die
frankreich die brennt jetzt ein bisschen
wenn ich dir sage okay dann kriegt
natürlich schon schaden aber wenn sie
jetzt hier so einfach drin steht dann
brennt sie vielleicht aber sonst
passiert nichts die brend einfach dann
hat sie wieder etwas trinken da an hand
und jetzt jeden moment hört auch noch
auf zu brennen und ich mache ich wieder
meine halbe karte da kaputt so jetzt
gleichauf zu brennen da jetzt aufgehört
zu weinen und hat gar keinen schaden
genommen
also wenn ich jetzt einen töten will
müsste die schon vernünftig töten und
nicht einfach irgendwie anzünden oder so
weil damals mittelalter war so da kommt
man jetzt einfach verbrennen
hexenverbrennung die stars hier ist das
gegenteil der fall so freunde der fun
fact heute ist ein etwas romantik effekt
und zwar können wir einfach ganz normal
eine lederjacke hier rot färben und
haben wir eine rote gefärbte lederjacke
und wenn wir diese lederjacke nun hier
einlegen und umdrehen quasi oder ich
weiß gar nicht wie es umdrehen müssen so
sieht's aus wie einher
ein bisschen kleinen bettchen wenn jetzt
ganz tapfer stellt dies bisschen aus wie
ein herz und new york wir können das
ganze ding aber auch noch herz nennen
denn wenn hens ja okay der fun factory
attacke aber ich dachte auch energie
schöner aus ok freuen wenn die coolere
fan fest dann schreibt man die einfach
in den kommentaren ich weiß doch nie was
warum ich das mit dem pfand überhaupt
eingeführt weil da denke ich dann immer
so ja muss ich dann irgendwie sowas
machen wo ihr lacht aber irgendwie muss
man darüber lachen
meine lieben freunde welches euch
trotzdem gefallen hat und eventuell ein
paar sachen dazu gelernt habt da sowas
ist jetzt nicht dazu denn das ist
einfach nur sofern mäßig dies dass dann
lasst doch eine bewertung dar und ihr
könnt noch weiter infekt schreiben ende
denkt zu ort also scheiße dieser fake
dann schreibt neue verbessere fact an
kontrast gmail.com damit es bei mir ist
mal wieder rein was gut und schaut